welcome
everybody to this evening's conversation
the loss of green
imaging vegetal worlds hosted by the mit
wiesner student art gallery
uh current artist and organized by her
nancy viadoras
my name is sarah herzl hi nancy
i'm the coordinator of the gallery for
anyone who has any questions or interest
in the gallery in the future
please let me know we will put a link to
the gallery in the chat
before nancy introduces her partner
samina long callison and shireen hamza
i want to invite everyone to submit
questions for the q a
using the chat function which we'll read
later please keep your microphone muted
during the event
um when our speakers are having their
conversation but later there'll be a
chance in the q a
for everyone um to participate and we
really encourage you to
rate use the raise hand button come on
screen and we look forward to a lively
conversation
without further ado i'd like to warmly
welcome
nancy vaidaris samina long callison and
shireen hamsa
thank you so much sarah um thank you
everyone for you know coming to the talk
um
so the loss of green imaging vegetal
worlds is part of
like you know sarah mentioned the online
exhibit that
i was invited to do at the wiesner
gallery
thank you so much sarah for all your
support and to all the
you know staff members who made this
possible um
so i i'm just going to give a very brief
uh description of what the work
is because there was already a um
gallery um sort of like walk through
which will be made available shortly
um and also the the the link to the show
will be put in the description at some
point which
you're more than welcome to go and take
a look at it um but
uh so my work was uh you know the
specific project mechanical ghost was
part of a three-year investigation
into the agricultural histories um and
botanical histories of honduras
specifically
uh in lanzatia botanical gardens which
is located in the north coast
um and you know my art practice is
a multidisciplinary offering for
botanical imaginaries
um and my thought of
this practice is the metabolism through
which internal becomings can happen
um and today i have the honor of
moderating
this talk between femina and shireen
um i'm very excited for the conversation
that will take place today
um so first that i will like to
introduce
samina um samina long collison is a
historian who recently received her
master's in architecture studies
in the history theory and criticism of
art and architecture
department from mit in 2020 um samina's
work examines colonial national museums
in denmark malaysia and singapore as
well as contemporary artistic practices
that respond to such institutions she
holds a ba in art history with
distinction from the university of
cambridge
and she was also a fiaco fellow and a
paulson researcher
at mit and is currently a fellow at the
curing museum of art in new hampshire
as well as a researcher at the mexico
city-based architecture practice art for
the lisp
her research is uh has been published in
the journal of the malaysian branch of
the rojo asiatic society
and the danish national gallery's
perspective journal
and today samina will share with us both
part of her research
and her recipe website garden blues
which is a personal iteration of the
work that she's done on the archive
um and shireen hamza is a historian and
current
a current phd candidate in history of
science at harvard university
um her dissertation project is a
reassessment of the concept of islamic
medicine by
studying scholarly medical traditions
across the indian ocean world
working on texts of both gallenic and
ayurvedic medicine composed in arabic
and persia between in arabic and persian
between the 13th and 15th centuries
she shows the coexistence of an exchange
between multiple traditions of healing
as well as the transformation of disease
categories and medicinal substances in
yemen in gujarat
her work has been supported by the
social science research council and the
fulbright commission
and she's the managing editor for the
ottoman history podcast and wrote and
produced ventricles a podcast on science
outside of the west
um so i would like to just you know
talk a little bit about um the thoughts
behind organizing this talk
and why samina and shireen you know had
the
i had the privilege of being in
conversation with them
and you know this kind of coming
together really
fluidly um and the dialogue between us
spans
uh several geographies and temporalities
um and
at this frosting of botanical exchanges
sensory encounters and archival
histories
um lie the practices of serena and
samina whose work i deeply admire
and have been inspired by
um this comes from an essay published by
prudence gibson on the color green
and i wanted to read to you a very small
excerpt
where she writes it is due to the lots
of green from our everyday habitats that
greenness
is more than a hue of nostalgia it has
also become a keen political weapon
an activated and dynamic arena of civic
and civil debate
thinking green is the same as thinking
for the long now
where plans and concepts need to have
longevity and long-distance strategic
clout
um so to me um this you know this this
phrase this title the loss of green
uh invokes the presence of an ecological
past
um what anna singh and donna haraway
refer to
as the plantation essene um
which has been ongoing through
negotiations of
what is considered to be living and
non-living
in some ways my desire for this talk was
to look at this
ecological present and speculate on the
future through the lens of
this vegetal past what does the now look
like after centuries of hybridizations
of bioprospecting and of the ongoing
extractive relationships between humans
and the vegetal world
both the mena and shireen's practices on
earth knowledge through different
sensoriums
from the sense of taste and smell in the
various cuisines that make their
appearance in simuna's project
garden blues to terrain's engagement
with prescriptions of plants and
medicinal practices
through the written word beyond solely
images both
both of their works take on the role of
animating the specimens and manuscripts
in the archive
what drew me to their respective
practices was how they engage with the
affect of these repositories
challenging and blurring the roles of
the historian and the witness
so please welcome both selena and um
shireen i am going to hand it over to a
first presenter
um which i believe is uh samina
i'm not mistaken um so i'm just gonna
kind of hand it over to you
and uh welcome
hi everyone um and thank you for joining
us tonight
it's so good to see so many friends and
familiar faces
and new ones too um nancy thank you for
the introduction
and for inviting me to be here i'm
excited to talk with you and shireen and
share my thoughts
with you guys and with everyone else
so um as nancy
mentioned my work focuses mostly on
british colonial history and colonial
history
in malaysia or malaya as it was known
and i've looked specifically at colonial
museums during the 19th century
they existed in most places in the
british
empire and were large repositories
of mineral and plant specimens
and the museums were important to
colonial administration
because they functioned as laboratories
that worked in the service of a general
search for revenue
so in malaysia these museums carried out
botanical experiments with
rubber and palm oil and eventually these
cash crops transformed the landscape of
malaysia
and turned it into a very lucrative
colony of one of the main exporters of
rubber and oil palm oil
so curiously later in the 20th century
museums came to play a role of
of guardians of nature they spearheaded
conservation
nature conservation as nature was
disappearing
outside the museum walls due to the
industries that the museums themselves
had
engineered so the museum has this double
role of both
destroying and preserving
and the colonial museum also became
a mirror of self for specific
parts of the independence movement in
malaysia
so they were initially part of a big
colonial infrastructure that rendered
malaya readable and exploitable and
governmental
but these collected artifacts and
specimens of
natural history were also adopted by
nationalist movements and they came to
represent a distinct
national identity so thoughts about
uh colonial botany and industries
and identity uh has been on my mind for
a while
um and when i met nancy a couple of
years ago
and we started cooking together we
realizing that
we realized that there were a lot of
overlapping flavors
um and this was a surprise to me
because in my head honduras was is very
far away from
malaysia but as we dug into the history
of these places
we realized that there were lots of
um the similarities were due to
the geographies being ports in the same
imperial networks
so hunters in malaysia are not formally
or fully part
of the same empires but people like
dorothy popino and wilson poppino who
are the protagonists so to speak in
nancy's botanical ghost her
her artwork um these two figures were
american
and british explorers and discoverers
who traveled to malaysia and honduras
and documented plant species there and
carried with them
seats from one botanical station to
another across the tropical belt
um so from my experiences uh
with cooking with nancy and from working
in the archive
emerged a more poetic iteration of
my research work
it's a recipe website called garden
blues which is inspired by
honduran and malaysian cuisine
and i'm going to share with you my
screen so you can see
the website
okay
um so
i should say that in creating this site
i've received a lot of help
especially from agnes cameron who
built it with me and who thought with me
about his story so
big thank you to agnes um so
the landing site is a bunch of gardens
and rivers that are named after memories
and themes and places
and each garden and river is populated
by
flowers a wavy little squiggles and if
you click on a flower
it will take you to a recipe that's
associated with the theme of the place
so um if we go to
the taiping lake gardens which is in the
north of
malaysia
um a recipe for
this coconut pan fried cake will come up
and if we go to garden of cash crops
down here
recipe for the beloved plantains will
come up
and then lastly
um if we go to the garden of blues
another dessert
uh will come up so the site also has
an index with a list of recipes
and a writing blog where i think about
the theory and the histories that is
behind the site
so um
[Music]
through food um i think this recipe site
tells a story about itinerant
colonial nature that thrives that travel
through the
the tropics and it also tells the story
of
about hybridity um i think it's a
pushback against
nationalist ideas of where things belong
um it's a pushback against authenticity
um and personally it's also
um disturbing the lines between what we
think of as local and foreign
um and i think it's in that way it's a
reflection of what it means to
come from a territory that is much
larger than
than the countries that we grew up in
um so that's it for me now i'm gonna
pass the
spotlight to shireen and stop screen
sharing
thank you thank you samina
thank you so much samina that was so so
interesting and i can't wait for the
discussion
um so i'm a historian of medicine
in the medieval indian or sorry the
medieval islamic
world a time before european empires
shaped
and were shaped by capital s science
and i spend my days reading manuscripts
written out over the centuries by
physicians who lived in the regions
bordering the indian ocean world the
manuscripts that you see
here all feature descriptions of plants
in alphabetical order
or rather those parts of plants that
were most relevant to medicine
so physicians needed to know the
therapeutic application of these
these parts but with the exception of
those few who actively foraged and
studied botany
they did not encounter plants growing in
their environments as
holes foragers farmers
traders they were the ones who supplied
markets with the dried roots
stems leaves flowers resins powders
that were actually used by physicians
and these processed forms of the plant
could travel
whether to local markets or to those
across
the ocean while there was a more
rarefied tradition of illustrated
botanical manuscripts
even these centered human uses of and
relations to
plants they never claimed to offer a
universal system of classification
the descriptions that you see here
included information on
where the plant grows its different
variants
the color of its usable parts and their
taste and smell
in relation to other medicinal
substances
these were a practical set of
comparisons
but when i close my eyes and try to
picture the history of botany
i don't actually imagine the millions of
extent pages of arabic and persian
manuscripts and libraries across eurasia
and the u.s
i see instead the bright illustrated
plant typologies of european colonial
botany
which i have encountered as framed
prince hung up on the walls of
countless inns cafes and shops
the more history i learn the more
sinister my encounters with these
aestheticized forms have felt
erasure after erasure as historian
daniela bashmara has argued
efforts to make the empire visible
always made parts of it
invisible the authors were those who
could lay claim to the intellectual work
of
observing and classifying writing it all
down in colonial languages
unmentioned were those doing the manual
labor of procuring the specimens or
of painting their portraits nancy's work
in botanical ghosts
brilliantly evokes the macabre lives and
afterlifes of these images
made by people who quote chose to accept
the death of many things
18th century naturalists aspired to
represent plants as
more real than reality a generalized
typology
accessible only with great skill and
difficulty
they were intentionally and aggressively
selective
extracting the typical from the
particulars of individual specimens
not quote distracted by irrelevant
details and
accidental traits a leaf torn by an
insect
a wilting flower or a flower not fully
bloomed
historians lori and daston and peter
gallison call this kind of knowing
truth to nature idealized botanical
images had
a generality that transcended the
species
to quote reflect a never seen but
nonetheless
real plant archetype but as bleichmara
and landa scheibinger have argued this
kind of botanical expertise
was so highly valuable in the 18th
century
where botany was quote big business
and big science botanical expeditions
were expensive
deploying large teams of naturalists
artists and laborers
and requiring the active participation
of a whole
imperial administrative apparatus
governors
treasury officials physicians
pharmacists clergymen
and many other local populations town to
town
in the americas botanical images were
implicated in their investors desires
for future profit
economic botany shaped the fate of
uncountable plants
and people who were commodified within a
plantation economy the violent ends to
which these images contributed
are another major difference from the
medieval traditions of botany and
pharmacopoeia that i study
nancy transforms idealized illustrations
of the ackee tree
into a uniformly grey rotating 3d model
gesturing at the continuity of truth to
nature in contemporary cultures of
scientific modeling
and defamiliarizing these ubiquitous and
highly aestheticized illustrations
in the narrative of botanical ghosts i
witnessed dorothy's
senses heightened her boundaries of self
dissolve into the specificity
of lancithia's lives and deaths
in imagining this intensely local story
in dorothy's lives the sense of
theirness that nancy describes
and um sorry in imagining this intensely
local story in dorothy's life
and the sense of fairness that she felt
nancy evokes a time skill that
transcends that of empire
and challenge challenges the totalizing
universal way
of seeing and classifying that the
linnaean system proposed
truth to nature images often divorced
plants from the environment where they
grow
and the culture and knowledge of the
people who cultivate or forage them
quote rejecting the local as contingent
subjective and translatable
favoring instead the dislocated global
as objective
truthful and permanent
a lot changed from the composition of
these medieval medical texts in the 14th
century
to carl linnaeus in the 18th to dorothy
popeno in the 20th
but i was really surprised to find a
moment of recognition in this sentence
of the narrative of botanical ghosts
dorothy told herself she was not one to
believe in spirits
especially the ones that she heard about
among the workers of lencitia
though learned medieval sciences were
not as totalizing as the modern sciences
have become
nor as separate or privileged within
hierarchies of knowledge
their practitioners still policed the
boundaries of their disciplines
while farmers miners traders and
foragers had valuable knowledge
physicians and botanists relied on to
learn local particulars and to locate
beneficial plant animal and mineral
substances
their names only seldom enter the texts
as sources
and do not have the same prestige as
those of ancient textual authorities
though these relationships were quite
different from that of dorothy's to the
workers on lancitia plan
on lenzitia the contiduity of scientific
exclusion
was one that i was unprepared to face
nancy does not dwell on this racist and
classist violence in dorothy's discourse
she mentions it somewhat obliquely
privileging instead the voice of the aki
tree
and dorothy's terrifying and
transformative encounter with it
at a recent union docs event artist
madeleine hunt erlich
spoke about the about abstraction as a
form of opacity
and opacity as a strategy used by black
artists as a way to protect themselves
and their audiences from historical
violence this struck me as an apt way of
understanding nancy's engagement with
the colonial archive of botany in
honduras
she still makes images to mediate
something
of this visual past however opaque the
transmission
but it is a history thoroughly haunted
by the radical vibrancy of plants
thanks thank you so much shireen
and samina both of you for these really
you know amazing and incredible
presentations of your work um
i'm very excited to you know start just
kind of jump into the discussion so we
have as much time as we can
um but um i really
i wanted to have like uh maybe i'd start
out with a question that both of you
could answer
about your experiences as you know
historians
um and you know
what i would really like to know a
little bit more
about um the sensory and effective
experiences that you've both kind of
experienced
um in these different archives and
repositories
um and sort of like
this you know the kind of things that do
not get written into
you know like you know the academic
texts and you know
these kind of projects that are um i
think
challenging these kind of boundaries
again of like historian and witness
and um i would like to kind of like
enter the conversation through so i was
wondering if
one of you could you know kind of jump
in um and we could just kind of unmute
and keep the conversation flowing
um i can i can start um
[Music]
yeah it's it's interesting how um behind
the writing of history there is a lot of
archive work
that goes into producing um
text which is not necessarily included
um i think something that i didn't
mention in my presentation and that also
doesn't come
through in the the recipe website is
that
in the natural realm included
um people and
um anthropological studies of people
were
also appearing in studies
of plants um
so there is this
curious the british natural history
includes both locals different races and
religion
um what today is categorized as cultural
artifacts
um but then in the early colonial
museums in the 19th century
these were categorized as as nature
and i was speaking to this a little bit
um in this idea of the
colonial museum transitioning into the
the national museum
so the natural resource both labor
and nature
later on becomes um this mirror of self
like uh locals see themselves mirrored
in
um in natural history museums
the the natural resource becomes like
this this
enters the cultural realm and becomes
like a cultural a resource
yeah yeah no that's so interesting and
to me
when you were talking about the um the
kind of porosity
of different empires and how you know
even though your two family histories
may be
kind of filed away into two separate
empires i think
i thought that was really interesting
how they you know they come together
in the in the kitchen at least um
and how we can't really just study
spanish empire or british empire
as two separate things um but i i also
love to hear what you said about the
relationship between museums and
conservation and the kind of like
temporality of
the past the idea of salvage that
animated so much of anthropology and
i'd love to hear at some point you say
more about um
about what museums you know what music
what role museums did play in this kind
of
idea of conservation but um yeah i i
kind of wanted to
to answer nancy's question by talking
about um
where all those manuscript images you
guys saw
like where i encountered them and um it
was
all in the uk and online
world digital library or like ul
universities by nikki library like
these are all places really diff like
far
and removed from the context where
these manuscripts were written so when i
go to
say like the british library's oriental
studies reading room which is like full
of these
portraits of like i don't know like
major kind of people in the co in
british colonial history
uh from asia and africa like it just it
feels so strange to me
there was a moment when i was there
during my dissertation research where
there there's a manuscript of a 14th
century
um pharmacological and medical texts
which is a persian text and the british
library has a copy of this text like
copied by the author's son so
it's really close to the author's life
and kind of
this is very kind of a precious sort of
object and
um i i don't know how many people ever
really order it or like want to see it
but
if it was in a different context you
know i think there would be a lot of
people who would be really happy to
be able to access that manuscript
somewhere maybe where persian is spoken
um and so those things happen like every
day and
it's so strange to be um like to know to
recognize that the knowledge system i'm
studying is hierarchical i'm not trying
to idealize it
but to to just be like you know to look
it in the face every day that this is
this is removed from its context um
either by theft
or by purchase under duress or any any
number of
of ways that these manuscripts kind of
make their ways into these libraries and
archives
and then to to balance that with like
the moments of discovery like moments of
like
oh this is so great for my research to
feel happy while
handling these manuscripts it it feels
very sort of like competing competing
moments and that's why i really
really connected with that aspect of
your project nancy
um this sort of like you know entering
an archive of violence but
finding very human narratives and
constructing in
and sort of speculating as to the
subjectivity of those people rather than
just
kind of shutting it out right um
yeah thank you so much serena and i mean
i think um that's something else that i
i thought that both of your you know
your works
were doing was also challenging
um very much the kind of uh
ways in which you know the construction
of nature
um you know what's happening through
different you know senses
um and i i briefly mentioned an
introduction
you know and samina and yours um it's
through this kind of like exchange of
like flavors and tastes
smells and cuisines you know that was
happening um
and uh shireen um through these kind of
like
description you know descriptions of
um you know plant species and medicinal
practices that
you know um require a certain
perhaps other kind of knowledge that is
i don't know if it
exists any longer or doesn't um but
you know i mean i was curious whether
there was any way in which these kind of
readings or expansions of the senses
when it comes to imagining vegetal
imaginaries
you know what can we learn today or what
are those things challenging um in terms
of
this very visual you know
you know history that centers vision as
the full way
of you know kind of constructing nature
or imagining
and remembering um and so
you know i i don't know i was curious to
hear a little bit more about that from
both of you because
um you know these things that like kind
of are engaging
uh you know different parts different uh
you know
essentially sensory encounters um in
history
uh i think challenged kind of existing
narratives
um so i was wondering if you could both
briefly talk about that
i don't know well um
i definitely i mean that was definitely
the point of the
zoom background just to show that like
for so many people using these plants
they're not there are no illustrations
in front of them you know they're not
encountering the plant as a whole
they're they're sort of reading and
memorizing
there's a lot of memorization involved
so the textuality of the practice
um i didn't include too many images of
a poetic text but like a lot of the
texts i'm looking at are in didactic
poetry so people can memorize them and
like
kind of the inseparability of object and
and text um whether that's like
memorized and oral or
or like being read aloud from a text is
really
is really present and those were often
comparisons they were often about
okay this this powder like of this root
will taste slightly more bitter than
this other things that you will
definitely have
tasted before and so i just you know it
evokes an image of these
um sort of folks in the bazaar in a
marketplace
like just tasting stuff and ingesting
ingesting medicines to make sure that
the quality and the
the sort of identification of the of the
of the substance is correct and it will
actually be therapeutic
um and i i i would like to say that this
like some forms of this medical
tradition are still practiced
and there definitely are people who um
who keep this alive whether it's
recognized by
postcolonial nations like india and
pakistan or in bangladesh where like
yunnani medicine is usually what it's
called today
is like a regulated by the state or
whether it's um
you know for example in the middle east
where or in parts of like east africa
um even west africa this sort of
tradition is practiced but um
it's not it's sort of not recognized in
the to the same level
in most of these countries like it's you
know bio medicine is medicine
and everything else is alternative or
traditional and
you know and and does face um because of
the lack of resources and lack of
regulation often um people are sometimes
you know harmed by it but people are
harmed by
biomedicine too so um
so it's pretty complicated but i i would
say that there are definitely
people who continue um to
uh to interact with um with medicines
through sense
senses like uh primarily smell and taste
more than sight but i also know that
those who practice this tradition today
their education is completely different
and has become
often has become biomedicalized and that
the site site
has thus um become more but yeah i
visited some of these schools of yunnani
medicine and
um like there's like a laboratory you
know like of
one of the classrooms um that i went to
had these jars
of just powders and and dried roots and
they had like
this is like a wall of jars and the
students who graduate from that need to
be able to identify
each of those without you know knowing
what what the label says so
there there definitely are people who
still are training in these ways of
of knowing yeah um i find that actually
also like a really good segue into a
question that i have for samina's work
which had to do with um this
relationship that you briefly mentioned
samina between
the museum the garden and the laboratory
which um
there seems to be this kind of like
continuity of transformation that
happens
you know um between you know these like
places that began as kind of like
experimental
botanical stations or or places for
you know essentially biology you know
essentially
a a kind of like laboratory and a plain
air
uh would then become these other things
um
and i would love to hear you talk a
little bit more about that and how it
comes about in your work
sure um so
the museum buildings would often have
attached to them
a smaller botanical garden where
the people who worked at the museums
experimented with
seeds and different
plants and i think what is
what we have talked about is that these
botanical institutions were in the
colonial
context were deeply involved with
extraction and dismay displacement of
people
and importing labor
but they were also strange places
where amateurs worked the british
colonial offices were not necessarily
trained or educated in biology or botany
so a lot of them were steered by
eccentric people who had bought botany
as a hobby
and a lot of the collections were
accidentally assembled
so these
collections do can come across as
encyclopedic and
shirin you mentioned like taxonomy they
can have this
very overwhelming and um powerful
impact on you but they were also often
chaotic bureaucracies
with small budgets and
when they were then passed on to like
thinking about the transformation where
they were passed on to
national movements um
they became sort of a nostalgic uh place
for what has one once been um
these uh they were sites of abundance of
a lost
uh diversity biodiversity
um so yeah i mean they are
they are strange the botanical gardens
the ones in honduras
and the ones in malaysia as well as
strange places because
they supposedly reflect a reality
outside
of their little delineated space but
those are
all usually quite extraordinary places
with a very high
um diversity yeah
yeah and i think um i mean speaking
and you know in terms of these like kind
of like delineations
um you know it's i i i cannot help but
think about
uh you know these sort of kind of
plantation logics that
would then emerge from um you know these
like really specific
kind of like express you know express
science of experimentation
and um you know unlessentia particularly
that experimental station you know
um it basically produced a matrix
of um of living things um
which uh you know kind of
plantation logic will attempt to you
know create
hierarchies and of organisms you know of
life
that are embedded into these like kind
of logics but
they have a history you know that kind
of comes from um
you know these all of these
relationships that um have been kind of
constructed throughout history
you know like um that are passed down
through these kind of like collections
um you know there's almost like an
assembly line
that that that produces these kind of
extractive relationalities
um and so i really find that
through by looking at these kind of like
histories you know like in
these kind of like collections small
collections one is able to kind of
almost see
into the present um and perhaps
extrapolate into the future
um and uh which brings me to another
question that i got to both of you
um i guess like
i don't know if this is maybe too so
much of a positive thing but
i was curious if you had thoughts on
what can be learned from these kind of
readings you know
of the vegetal imagination botanical
kind of like history
um for our present and then these things
you know
um you know help us
create other imaginaries and other
relationships to
nature and uh you know to plants the
vegetable world
so um yeah i don't know if any of you
have any thoughts on that
i i've honestly not been thinking about
this that long
like i know there are people here who
are like thoroughly plant
people and i don't think that i've kept
a plant
alive for longer than like three or four
years so
you know they're still alive but like
this is a relatively recent chapter in
my life so
maybe i should let others say um like i
want to plug the work of nicholas roth
who's on the skull um who's doing an
amazing
project about botany and early modern
south asia across
persian and rajbasha and like he's like
a plant person you know he sees like a
painting and he's like this is this
plant this is that plant
which is awesome but i have been really
influenced
by um natasha meyer's idea of the
plantarpuseen
and just the idea that
moving somewhere different like breaking
the trajectory of consumption and
climate crisis would really require
tuning into other ways of sensing
and of being something that i think
nancy you call
microbial subjectivities and vegetal
life which i just loved
um yeah but samina i don't know if you
have thoughts on this
yeah i mean during you you your
work is about medicine and in a way
healing
um and i want to return to
the idea of the botanical gardens or the
museums the colonial museums as
kind of contradictory spaces
the certain botanical stations
at least that i'm familiar with in
malaysia
served for instance as retreat places
for
um victorian english women
who had been diagnosed
with like frail health
um so i think that is a curious um
doppelness to the to the gardens
um i also think it's i mean through my
little
personal food projects and garden blues
it's um thinking about healing
through these places that have done so
much harm i don't know if that
is actually possible but
i do think that there's a lot of value
in deepening a knowledge
about these places and it gives you a
broader perspective of how we ended up
here
yeah oh go ahead no i was gonna ask
shireen about
um about hybridity uh
and plant exchanges
perhaps um before the colonial encounter
and if you can speak to that a little
bit more
sure yeah i've been really influenced by
um
project mukherjee's concept of braided
knowledge
for ayurveda um really thinking about
i mean he's working on the colonial
period but he's pointing out that
all of the you know so-called great
great traditions
um were already um hybrid and
and plural even you know when they
started to be encountered by europeans
um more frequently from the 16th century
onward and so
um definitely it has been fascinating
for me to be studying
ayurvedic ideas in persian and
the kind of selectiveness also of which
things are
are translated and which things are not
um
so i think like uh there's a different
feeling about it
because about those kinds of um ratings
uh because uh their science was not
like totalizing it was not implicated
so deeply in how the state governs and
the state
did not have as invasive a presence
in the lives of most individuals as the
modern state
and so i feel like the stakes of the
question are quite
different than um in say the 19th
century
but but yeah i do i do really um
even though hybridity has gotten a lot
of flack from
a lot of people for for good reasons um
i think it's really important to think
about traditions as always already
hybrid
yeah thank you so much um so we actually
just got a really great
question from caroline jones
hi caroline thank you so much for coming
um
so it's uh uh she asked i'm curious
about the gender threat in the
discussion
in western early modernism which is
where the females in command
of botany and cures the
professionalization of curing was a
gender control project among other
things
um how does nancy and samina and shireen
see this question in their non-western
context
um and yeah that is a really great
question i don't know if either of you
like wanna go like
definitely i mean i kind of want to aim
at you nancy because
you know you've got a complicated
intersection here with the colonialist
who's female yep right
so you know i know that um you know
schiebenger's work
is about you know as well as natalie
davis
about someone like sabila marion
going on the ships of discovery and then
talking to the women about the
abortifacients
yeah right so so there's like a
a possibility of intersectionality there
that's interesting
but in your different context it might
just
right it might just be kind of cancelled
out and for shireen
i'm also inspired by the work of um the
htc phd student metha
amano zuzi maybe you know her anyway
she's working on poison manuals
which are always like written by men
about like
women you know as the ones who have to
hold the potion or you know to put some
of their urine in it or what
like it's it's very wet wrapped through
the female world of these
islamic medieval texts she's looking at
these poison manuals but
like the women are are not doing the
writing you know
so anyway it's just a grab bag question
but i'd love to
to know what you all think about these
flows of power yeah absolutely um i
you know i would like to sort of like
address the question of dorothy which is
one that
um you know caroline you were there at
the very
sort of beginning of this inquiry and it
it's um
i will have to admit that i i don't
think i have a right to a conclusion of
what my relationship to this character
dorothy specifically is it's a very
complicated one
it's an acknowledgement that she you
know in her
um uh
you know like she essentially helped
perpetrate and you know spread
um you know a very specific kind of uh
of violence
um you know while at the same time
producing you know knowledge that was
um you know you know at the time you
know
considered perhaps maybe forbidden or
um i i think that
in some ways like um
the question of the control of gender is
is is really interesting um
and and it brings me maybe to
think about maybe more about the present
um
because i think that there have
definitely been a sort of revival
of um you know these you know practices
that are
uh you know perhaps considered
like maybe pseudoscience or there's been
a sort of like revival of
um you know uh
you know herbalism and essentially
witchcraft
um and it i believe that it kind of has
transcended
in some ways uh gender and we have a
sort of like new
uh you know vision of what to relate
this relationship to magic
and the occult and which is deeply
deeply related to you know this kind of
like botanical relationship what that
might look like today
um and
i don't know i i feel that uh samina i
really hear what you like
you know talked about with uh you know
like these idea this idea of healing and
curing
and you know that like knowledge was you
know this kind of botanical knowledge
was also
in some ways gendered uh or
or this kind of like way of being in the
garden was
you know specifically also um like a
kind of
yeah very pointed you know
yeah sorry i'm getting tongue-tied but
um yeah caroline i feel like it's it's
very it's
complicated and i don't think i've
arrived to any kind of conclusion or
kind of terminal point um
good artistic position
yeah i i mean thank you so much for this
reference i'm going to follow up um
for the name of the scholar you
mentioned i'd also like to kind of point
to sarah verskin's book
veren women which just came out last
year
and it's um it's really interesting
because she
is deeply interested in um
in women's knowledge and women's
experiences but
her you know her sources from the
medieval islamic world are all written
by men
and i believe she's primarily working in
arabic she also reads
some hebrew sources as well but um
what what really comes through from that
book like something i'm really taking
away from
it is the intensity of male anxieties
around women's knowledge in women's
spaces
and um it's it's just astounding
sometimes to read especially like
legal scholars um not as much physicians
but intensely for legal scholars like
islamic religious scholars or
how they are concerned and they're not
concerned about witchcraft and magic
explicitly
but what they are concerned about is
that
you know they have the real islam they
have the proper and textual islam as
as male scholars and when women get
together around especially around like
intense moments of of life and
transition like birth
they don't know what kind of practices
they're transmitting and they don't
they don't want that to happen without
somebody being there some man being
there kind of
saying what the real what the real islam
is
and so i think that unfortunately like
um as it became kind of clear to me
reading this book
there there aren't always going to be
questions that we can answer
about you know what women's spaces
looked like and what
what their knowledge looked like in this
period just because they were
except in particular disciplines like
hadith uh
prophetic kind of traditions they were
largely excluded from textual production
um so yeah that's it's been hard to
grapple with that
with reading that book this year
yeah um i think i also had like a
comment on this before we wrap up this
we're very close
but uh do you want to go ahead and yeah
i can
share um my thought briefly so
i think it's a really interesting
question because a lot of the colonial
offices and civil servants that i that i
look at and who left behind the archive
and the colonial museums were men
but the travel logs there are quite a
few travelogues of
victorian women who traveled across the
british empire and met
all of these civil servants and
um and documented their conversations
and described their character and how
they interacted with the locals their
relationship with the locals
so in a way this travel locks for me was
this more like
backstage human relationship what's
going on um
between the the colonial offices um they
were written
by these women who were very wealthy and
they spent their life just traveling
around
um but yeah i think that's an at least
in the the text that i've encountered
there's a different kind of
category of text that women would have
written
um and travel lock or like botanical
illustrations in those
and those travel vlogs is one of them um
that is
specifically uh speaks to the gender
question
yeah the erasing
yeah um and it's yeah it's also
interesting i mean a lot of botanical
illustrators were women
um and it was uh
you know for example uh you know in my
project in particular project dorothy
dorothy popino
um produced a lot of the illustrations
that
um uh that wilson pope and her husband
who was a really famous botanist
um you know published uh and it was this
kind of
like um you know
labor of you know like reproducing you
know this kind of like
you know knowledge that was still you
know kind of
almost blanketed and obscured by you
know the
the sort of almost like monumentalizing
of of wilson popenos kind of career
um and uh so
okay sarah just gave me like the little
signal that we're very
close to wrapping up tonight um but if
you know anyone would like to kind of
like stay afterwards and ask any more
questions you're more than welcome to
um but uh i wanted to say you know thank
you also
to everyone who came and to samina and
shireen
um so if you know you'd like to stay
and ask a couple more questions you're
more than welcome to but
um you know if you know you have to go
also no worries um but thank you so much
sarah and uh you know the wiesner
gallery
for opening up this opportunity in this
space for having this really amazing
conversation
uh you know with these two historians
and also artists in their own right
this work i deeply admire uh so thank
you very much everyone
um and yeah hopefully see you soon
thank you so much to our amazing
panelists yes and those friends who want
to stay you're welcome
um but really we appreciate everyone's
participation thank you so much thank
you
hi nicholas uh this is
um
sort of bundle of questions i'm you know
might
um uh
not sure how useful it is but um uh and
how much is just my my own sort of
concerns but
um one thing that i was sort of
wondering about is um
you know i was just talking about sort
of um colonial
imperial context with large and uh and
as opposed to sort of a pre-colonial or
colonial uh context that you with your
work showing um i wonder to what
degree like
you think that that there's a
there's a peculiar that there are sort
of peculiarities
um and whether they matter
to um to botanical science as
as implemented or as as
promoted by particular
so you know western colonial
quote-unquote cultures particular
empires especially with
with the sort of obsessive centrality to
british
imperial identity that the botany has
for the brits to the point where even
where
where they weren't you know where
british botanists are and and and
lady travelers who produce botanic
illustrations
are all over the place even in colonies
that aren't historically
british um and
and that you know and there's this
particular sort of pattern of of
um that has been relatively well studied
and documented uh
of gardens in particular british
colonies um
like malaya like in like india and that
have a particular end up having
particular relationships
to the two of the local elites and and
their production of knowledge around
this
uh on this stuff um
versus sort of you know other european
empires that where there where i think
we have a comparatively more spotty um
record even though i mean she even
mentioned uh danielle blackmart's work
on on botany and in the sort of um
iberian colonial world uh but
they're like how how do those
differences in those dynamics matter i
was just thinking now with the
you know we have so many in the sort of
ang you know
anglophone slash germanic world from
early on you know with
marion and so on we have all these women
producing botanical illustration
uh but then for this for the spanish
imperial expeditions we have
indigenous mexican artists who are men
but who are you know mexican born and
mestizo
like were are there perils or
connections there
bundle of questions that might or might
not be useful can i add one question
nicholas since you're
here which is like how do you think
about gender
in botany and in your work in early
modern south asia
i um i haven't engaged with it
um very thoroughly so far
uh because working off
you know like you know
16th through 18th century south asian
sources
i have so few um
i have so few female voices in the
record
um so where where i've touched upon
it has merely mostly been in regard in a
way in the way that
um that horticultural spaces
and and and horticultural labor is
imagined
and though and and there women you know
women feature i think relatively
prominently but
but that almost the point of it sort of
being a poetic con like
sort of a literally conceit i think but
it's
but this is always with the caveat that
these are the
you know the the imaginings or ideals of
male authors
um at least in the in the work that i've
materials i've looked at so and and
sort of patterns that i've looked at so
far
thank you so much nicholas for that
question um i'm an artist and so i feel
like i'm not qualified to answer
anything
you know but um i don't know if you have
an answer
or like a response um or
if anyone would also like to follow up
with another question
uh you're more than welcome to meet
yourself and also ask one
i think uh what what came to mind i
think this is more response than an
answer
um i
the the botanical stations and the hill
stations that i'm familiar with um
we're both experimental gardens where
british colonial offices in malaysia
collected species from across
the empire and also territories beyond
but they were at the same time um
also little miniature versions of
british gardens
so i think this comes back to um
yeah the contradictory spaces that these
places are it's
both a place of foreign
quote-unquote foreign imported seeds and
plants but they were also
green spaces where i think the british
made themselves feel at ease or at home
like rose gardens were built next to
experiments with tobacco and silk
and especially in the hills where the
climate was more
suitable for european plants um
yeah so there's that the the strange
kind of coexistence
in these gardens i yeah that's uh
a comment i think for unit clubs
wow that just reminds me of um
i'm not super versed in the scholarship
but
um this you know the production of
persian gardens all over south asia
and and kind of like the post you know
14th century like explosion of
um these forms yeah we actually kind of
have like an expert
here to talk about that but yeah i just
i think that
that like i'm trying to like grapple
with the part of nick's question which
is like
what does what is the distinction say
for example between the expansion of
like
persian style gardens under the
sultanate into south asia
and the kind of british gardens you're
talking about semene
and i feel like it really comes down to
um to both labor and epistemology like
it's it can't just be like oh the
exportation of like
ideas and aesthetics like it really also
has to do with like the very unique
um kinds of like racialized forms of
labor that emerge i think in european
empire
and um i just i don't think that though
there are
are certainly like social hierarchies in
all parts of the world
um and like cast deserves mention for
sure for south asia
they're just not um i think yeah that
shifts as well in the modern
you know and um i feel like
i always come back to labor when i'm
trying to say like what's the difference
between
pre-modern and and and modern empire
labor and as well as like
um just the the totality of scientific
discourses like
some of the like what you were saying
nicholas like what what do we do with
these like idealized
representations of women for example or
of specific sub
like groups or subgroups of people by
elite writers
well those things they were producing
didn't actually like
transform into policy you know they
didn't sort of become
an imperial apparatus that then govern
those people's lives
um at least not immediately or not tote
in a total way
so i feel like that's a difference too
yeah thank you so much um yeah i guess
like one thing i was also
thinking about uh maybe to kind of bring
it to a completely different scale
and you know um maybe direction
is um you know in some ways like i think
uh these kind of legacies of you know
plant representation and
um you know i think a lot about
i think history of photography is being
deeply entangled with
the history of um you know botanical
representation
and illustration um you know and uh
you know in some ways like i i feel that
um you know it's this kind of like
pursuit of
you know chlorophyll of light you know
of like greenness
um that kind of led to the
creation of a lot of technologies of
vision you know of like
of visualization of preservation
um and uh you know that has been like a
really
kind of uh you know central um
yeah you know just kind of central theme
for some of like you know
my practice and i feel it's underlying a
lot of these kind of questions of
uh you know colonial networks of
exchange and what
what was kind of like the driving force
behind a lot of these
um you know exchanges and
transportations
um and you know the i don't want to
forget about
i guess like the
the plants themselves you know the kind
of vegetal agency
um and you know who is actually
cultivating
whom uh you know where was it humans who
were actually the drivers of these
exchanges or did plants themselves
um kind of
cultivate us um you know to transport to
move you know whose desires are
kind of like looking at um and so that
is a kind of question that i've been
kind of thinking
about for a while which i don't know uh
you know
running kind of like way over time but
um
you know i just wanted to kind of bring
that into the conversation
um but i think maybe this is a good time
to wrap it up
um you know i wanted to thank everyone
again sarah thank you so much for
um you know for everything samina and
shireen
i am so grateful and so inspired by both
of you and i hope that
we can continue this conversation
further um
and you know um i'm really looking
forward to
you know to see what else you guys are
working on
um thank you everyone for being here
and have a good night